Timothy shalam is better looking than
Tom Holland oh man y going for the S
he's a dog
D good looking Department this is the
loudest agree to disagree this has got
to be the most voluminous
[Music]
one so first question is
Squirtles let's go here we go it's time
to go it's time to go okay French is the
sexiest language ooh ooh oh I strongly
agree strongly agree I strongly agree
that French is the sexiest language I'm
going to hit an oval okay interesting
I'm going to hit an oval right here
me because on some days it's French but
other is I like Italian oh do you yeah I
think Italian super sexy Italian I think
Italian's super sexy what do you like
about the Italian accent I just think
it's smooth you you do you can you can
allow to do the accent if you want in
different way he speaks the French by
the way who's seen you know his ke peel
French waiter sketch have you seen that
sketch Russ would you
care thing as a French person is it
sounds it does it sounds real it sounds
real but as a French speaker do do you
feel it
sexy somewhere in the middle somewhere
somewhere in the middle whereas when I
hear Italian I'm like you know damn
how do you feel about British I like the
hull accent you like Hall yeah why is
everyone cracking up why is that is that
is it not is it not a sexy accent H is
sexy what's wrong with hle I like Hall
Essex is my top three everybody likes
Essex and like a a middle-age Northern
accent so middle-age Yorkshire middle
middle-age that was a
great just a short b a lot a American
football is a better sport than
basketball I'm going to go um I think
that I agree that it's better Yik why
why do I agree that it's better I might
CH hold on I think I might agree with I
might agree with Timmy that I disagree
and why is that you have to really
really really understand American
football to to like it and and and
basketball I think is a simpler Sport
and it's Al super fluid it's really
fluid it's nonstop it keeps on moving
you know what I mean so there's that if
you now I I Adore yeah American football
you know I you know I be American
football I love my Detroit Lions I love
my Detroit Lions shout out Jerry golf
yeah who is that for the UK audience uh
for the UK audience uh Jared gof is the
quarterback for the Detroit Lions
American football team dog he's a
straight
dawg which for the UK audience means
that he's
good D he's a
dog Timothy are you a big basketball fan
I'm a big basketball fan yeah I'm not
nearly skilled or athletic enough to
play at a high level but um you play at
a low level I play at a
midlevel definitely play no I've seen
him play he plays it a mid level it's
definition strong to the right weak to
the left weak to the left weak to the
left not strong to the left yeah yeah
some the it right that on your first
paycheck did you get a basketball game
or something and the LeBron James Ami St
so so the so yeah the summer of Summer
of 2010 we were dying for LeBron James
to come to New York M oh right yeah yes
yes and then we got Amari which was
amazing he did very well did really well
so he was a beast then we got Carmelo
quickly after that y I thought like
LeBron was going to come and the ticket
prices were going to run up that wasn't
the case so I ended up sort of like yeah
running a negative on those season
tickets but you know it was a good it
was a classic team than are good this
year though it's all about the Jaylen
Brunson dog
DW dog again for the British good
someone who's skilled someone he goes to
the left and the right left and the
right left and the right Timothy shalam
is better looking than Tom Holland oh
man y y'all going for the sou oh oh
y'all just pulling out lances what is
going on I'm going strongly disagree on
that Tom is the ultimate Riz m
internet knows this Zenda knows this
everyone knows this ultimate rizm I love
Tom's my buddies so so you you just I
can't can I no no no no no I'm just my
guts saying that I'm oh Tim I don't know
Tim I don't know OT I don't know I think
you got to go in this I got to go in the
what if I just do this what if I just do
this did we say it's imperceptible how
much I moved that com yeah yeah yeah
need a v on that yeah we do need a v
okay there is a reason why we've done
this we do have a clip of Tom Holland
talking about this exact subject who is
better looking Tom Holland or who do you
think is the other gun it's going to be
Timothy shalamay I bet you put him up
there no cuz he's double handsome and
I'd lose that one I think Timmy I think
you've got the classic look I think I
love Tom paid a lot of money for this
look it's working brother it'sing cuz
you're the
D
dog straight
dog good looking Department this is the
loudest agreed disagree agree to
disagree agree to disagree disagree this
has got to be the most voluminous one
agree to dis agree.com yeah sure okay
okay okay nice nice nice a straw has one
hole not two holes ooh oh okay that's
good straw has one hole not two holes
mhm
M I'm I'm going to let you
go provoking I'm going to go with my
gut I'm going to I'm going to I know I
know where I'm going now I'm going to
strongly strongly disagree
o okay I really feel that if you have a
border that creates a new hole there's a
border of circular on both sides of the
straw that leaves one with two holes as
opposed to to one hole so I believe that
there's two holes in a straw that's I I
believe it
wholeheartedly I believe it passionately
that there's two holes on a straw it's
it's the amount of oh wait wait wait
because what happens is there's a hole
on this side and a
ho I'm blowing through a horn right now
that has two holes okay there's one at
the mouth at the mouth then I think like
a I think it's one hole you just see
through it are you you want to sit in
the chair I'll talk you out of it I'll
talk you out of it I'm saying I agree
it's true he did fully no you fully
talked me out of it it's true there's
two sides there's two sides wait what
would happen if the bottom of the straw
was filled in then then there would be
one hole okay if you if you pinched the
bottom of the straw that's one hole if
you leave it be that's two holes right
and so I strongly disagree with all of
my heart and my liver my spleen my
everything I he talks about this once a
week right now thinking we have lunch
that's this is all I talk about I'm a
better rapper than the person opposite
me
ooh I'm a better rapper than the person
opposite me I don't know if I've ever
heard you rap no no I strongly disagree
I'm going to go strongly disagree too do
you really you think that I can wrap it
out I can't take that L hitting the
agree or the strongly
that's so funny cuz I am not I'm not
like the biggest hipop Maven and so for
me it's hard I mean you know I don't
know what I want to be but I can see
that it's me what don't have another
rhyme because I don't even know what
time
dog it's all about me am I the
dawg yes you are what no
oh
no I have no idea that I just came out
that just came out of nowhere no those
were bars was I spitting bars yes yes I
F I felt the little chill run up my SP I
feel like you you Love Hip Hop I do love
hip-hop I do love hip-hop I just feel
like you could spit bars no no no no
history would say otherwise but no there
was there's an alternate would say
otherwise his history his his history
would say otherwise yeah put a little
strangle on that just give me a little
scang
strangle on that keep that stuff in when
we're doing that that's that's the stuff
that's the stuff that's screams
Wonka I can do a better hug impression
than the personal me no I'm going to go
strongly disagree on that no I can't do
better hug I feel like I agree I I I an
impression I feel am I see am I doing it
right cuz I feel that I I I I I I could
do a pretty good h
uh I will have you know that I am a
perfectly respectable size for boom oh
no oh no 30 plus years man it's a legend
he's where it's at I'm talking nodding
Hill talking Four Weddings and a
funeral you could have you could have
you could have you could have thrown
another funeral up in that movie Four
Weddings in two funeral funeral you I
mean that's that's that's the sequel he
just hasn't made it yet in development
British chocolate is better than
American chocolate
ooh over here oh okay over here W sh
fire strongly agree I British chocolate
is better than American chocolate 100
you want to try some American British
uhhuh so that's the the one that you all
know from so these like these have trans
fats are these Americans that's American
they have trans fat these have trans
fats they have trans fats in
them illegal in other
countries delicious it's good delicious
yeah
mhm mhm mhm mhm mhm where where's your
glass going that's most important I mean
oh it's so good I don't know they're
both pretty damn
good Spike Le voice not my cup of
tea he's strongly disagreed you is that
a serious serious wow you genuinely
think that no I just wanted to use that
Spike Le quo
okay every movie would be made better
with a Muppets remake
ooh oh I'm going to have to to strongly
agree on that if you were going to make
a
remake of Dune right uhhuh with Muppets
that would cuz I just want to see Zinda
as a muppet you know what I mean she
still be amazing should be yeah she
would be she would be just as beautiful
just as captivating eyes wide shot
Muppets eyes
watch Muppets with masks on them yeah
that would be hard call me by your name
Muppet call me by your name Muppets call
me by your name Muppets call me by your
your by
your he's the comedic
mind I'll start a thought and I think
it's going somewhere it's like like a
tweet like a tweet did I just do that I
just did that didn't I yeah save like
I'd like to see like the Matrix Matrix
muet all that green screen all that
green all that GRE or liveaction Muppets
could you imagine just a little frog
Kermit like can you imagine Kermit is
just a real frit
impression um
Kermit I almost just said Kermit the
Frog here is that right that was great
Kermit the Frog here for Muppet news we
should do this live action yeah live
action Muppets yeah oh that was great
guys that's we at of time we're at of
time that is sad s this was a good this
was so
fun dog you you a dog Becky D I like
American football I just don't
understand why it's called football cuz
they don't use their feet yeah it should
be cly different maybe throwball
whatever you want to call it but you
don't kick it you do kick it yeah once
but once